I feel like I would have to find a table
at waist-length
it's like elephants me I can't just go
at it with the razor I mean we're
talking about over in here like let's
get it
I think balls are the ultimate proof
that there is no guy really yeah well
because they're so ugly God could have
made our genitals beautiful and he
picked balls I'm just saying I don't
think balls are the ugliest thing in the
world they're definitely like bozo my
club nice set of balls
I don't even know guys shave their balls
I've just seen here anyone yeah I've
never shaved I've trimmed my balls now
it's just like this is how it's supposed
to be I stay in my lane I will never
bring a razor for that area this is
where we generate humans and it's a very
fragile place can anybody really be like
pro ball hair is that a thing people are
like oh yeah ball hair but have you cut
your balls there is an occasional Nick
that can occur but again don't be a baby
it's fine I've gotten cut just from a
trimmer verbal if I was bleeding for now
there I would immediately call 9-1-1 and
I would like to rub it on the walls like
I'm dying like on the mirror there would
be a bloody hand it wasn't that bad it's
just like cutting yourself anywhere else
it didn't hurt that bad okay if I'm
hooking up with someone and they haven't
shaved I'm not like oh my god but if
you're gonna expect of me to be shaved
then you better be too sure also I think
it's a weird thing where it's not
feminine or like oh it's a good shave
shut up it's not like a smooth surface
so I feel like you would need to just
iron board that bad boy like a t-shirt
like ironing a wrinkled t-shirt but with
the razor it's been the scrotum is
almost a liquid it could it can fill any
container it could fill like in between
where it's not supposed to go and get
cut pretty easily
I'm trying to analyze that I just I
can't imagine any girl I've dated being
like oh man I just wish there was more
ball hair
I think getting help shaving your balls
might be kind of fun and kind of like
you might kind of be like this is an
interesting way to like do some foreplay
if I met a sinop you know that I really
care about and she's like hey this
really makes me happy would you mind
trying it out I'll try it and if it
sucks then I wouldn't do it again I
think that they are your balls and you
should do whatever you'd like personally
I would not shave mine I guess it
depends on what your partner likes you
know there's some people out there like
it Harry Sperry and there's some people
who don't I just think for me as long as
it's not like Wolverine down there it's
cool
well
[Music]
got a crick in my neck and I wonder if
I'm
you